cardi B hits a career milestone it's so  crazy like she's shy you know what to  say mom modak yellow the infectious  trapped hit of the summer just knocked  Taylor Swift from the number one spot on  Billboard's Hot 100 chart that makes  cardi B the first unaccompanied to  female hip-hop artist to top the chart  in nearly 20 years it was all the way  back in 1998 that Lauren Hill's that  doo-wop that thing took the same spot  [Music]  the 24 year old rapper was pretty  emotional after she got the news been a  very emotional day party games for  downloading downloading downloading to  my friends my family for recalling it to  all these artists that were showing me  so much love those artist showed cardi  more love after the announcement both  Missy Elliott and Nicki Minaj  tweeted it Congrats I can't even cry  anymore I can't do it to myself thanks  so much for everything